Okay Charles so we've been talking
about temporal difference learning.
And in particular various flavors
of the TD lambda algorithm.
Can you remember some of the important
things that we've touched on?
>> Well I think you
just said the big one.
That all this discussion has really
been about temporal difference learning.
>> And in a nutshell what's
a temporal difference?
>> Well it's the difference
between things you see on
different subsequent time steps.
>> What kind of things
in different time steps?
>> Reward.
>> So, sort of the difference in value
estimates as we go from one step to
another, right?
>> That's exactly right, because value
is just a nice summary statistic for
long-term reward.
>> Good, all right.
>> But actually, I think it was
important that you started off talking
about this is the thing that we wanted
to do, but first you put it in context.
By talking about different
ways that we could solve
the reinforcement learning problem.
As I recall, there were three ways to
think about it: model based learning,
value based learning, and
let's say policy based learning.
>> That's right and
TD methods kind of fall where?
>> In the value based.
>> All right then, we dove into
the update rules themselves.
So what do we talk about there?
>> We actually deroved?
>> [LAUGHS] Derived?
>> Either one of those things.
It's just semantics.
This kind of incremental way.
Of building up estimates of the values,
and I think you called it outcome based.
And I suppose all that really means,
of course, is that you actually look at
the outcomes of what you experience
from different trajectories.
And episodes through the space,
and you use that to build up
your sort of estimate of what
the values of various states are.
>> Yeah, and in particular,
the idea of an outcome based says, well.
You can kind of treat
reinforcement learning as a kind of
supervised learning.
Just wait for time to stop and
see what happened, and
use that as a training example.
But we can't really wait for
time to end,
because it's kind of too late to
use any of the information there.
So what we want are incremental methods,
methods that can actually
do updates along the way.
That would be equivalent to
waiting until the end, but
actually gives us results sooner.
>> Right, and there was a technical
point that you made that I guess is
something that we learned about.
Which we had talked about in
the old machine learning course but
we didn't go into any detail about.
Which is this sort of incremental update
by making it look like a supervised
learning rule, just look like
the normal perceptron update rule.
And it had a learning rate.
And in order for us to be sure that
we're going to learn something that we
wanted to learn, that learning rate
had to have certain properties.
>> Great, that's exactly right.
And in a nutshell,
what were these properties that
the learning rate had to have?
>> Well, let's see, that the sum over
all the learning rate values, so
let's call that Alpha T for
time, needed to be infinite.
And that the sum of the learning
rate squared needed to be finite.
>> Yeah, so intuitively we want a
learning rate sequences that would allow
us to move the value to wherever
it needed to go, to converge.
But would dampen overtime, decay so
that the estimates wouldn't keep bumping
around as a function of the noise.
>> Right, I think that's great.
Well, anyway I think that pretty
much brought us to the end.
We took a lot of slides to get there,
but it turned out the algorithm that we
derived looked a lot like something we
call TD(1) give it a nice little name.
And TD(1) was very nice
except it was inefficient.
In the way that it used data.
>> Yeah, I don't know that everybody
would agree exactly with that
way of characterizing it.
But it is true that it had this
sort of weird property that it was,
there's a lot of variability in it.
There was a very high variance,
because if we had one run,
we had a value that we're
estimating from one place and.
The estimate was based
on a very noisy example,
then we're going to have
a very noisy estimate.
It wasn't going to be able to use
the rest of the examples that it's seen
to kind of smooth this out.
>> Right it didn't use
information along the way.
It used information sort of
at the end of every episode.
And that's what made it
sort of data inefficient.
And I guess in the end that
gives you high variance.
But we came to the rescue and
when I say we I mean you came
to the rescue with TD(0).
Which has the nice property that it
gives you the maximum likelihood
estimate.
>> I prefer to think of it as
the Micheal Litman estimate.
>> Yeah, I know you do.
I've see how you snuck that in and then
it got us to the very end which is good
because you're running out
of space on the slide.
We generalize TD1 and
TD0 into something we called TD lambda.
>> That has the property that when
lambda is zero we get TD(0) and
when lambda is one we get TD (1).
What about the intermediate values?
>> Well,
then that just gives you dubstep.
>> Wait what?
>> It gives you dub step.
You get the dub step look ahead.
[SOUND] [SOUND] [SOUND]
>> [LAUGH] I see that's right,
multiple steps of updates.
I see what you mean by dub step,
like double the number of steps.
>> Oh yeah I like that.
That sounds like I meant to do that.
Yeah let's go with that.
And there you go,
I think that's just about everything.
Oh, one more thing, is that you talked
a little bit about different values of
lambda and why you might
choose one value over another.
And it turns out that values
of lambda between 0.3 and
0.7 empirically seem
to work pretty well.
Yeah, because it's somehow
making a nice trade-off
between estimating the right
kind of quantity and
estimating it using the values
that you get from looking ahead.
>> Right, and
first off that's neat because otherwise
you wouldn't need to have TD lambda.
But it's in some ways
a little surprising.
>> Why is that?
>> Well because it kind of
just works out the way that
you would want it work out.
You went through all this trouble to
kind of generalize between things.
You have this kind of highly
non-linear way of combining
all the different k step look aheads.
And it terms out that combining them so
it's not quite 0 it's not quite one
is better than either 0 or 1, and
often that's not how it works.
Right, I mean often it's like
a line from 0 to 1 is bad.
It's like a line, or
it gets really better,
then it sort of flattens out
towards the end, like you said.
But, in this case it just gets better,
and better, and better, and
then it starts to get worse when
you go from one end to the other.
>> Yeah that's right.
So
often when you combine two good things,
you get the worst of both.
In this case, it does somehow
manage to get the best of both.
>> Yeah, that's pretty cool.
>> All right, so what I'd like to dive
into next is a deeper understanding of.
How we could show that these kinds
of methods actually converge, and
they actually produce optimal estimates
and optimal behavior in the limit.
And so
we're going to take a step back and
look at the Belmont
equation again to do that.
>> Oh I like it.
I love the Belmont equation.
>> All right see you then then.
>> All right see you, bye.